les adolescents c'est comme les chevaux
c'est toujours mal coiffée samu ce que
les céréales les jeunes chantier sur
l'écurie françois xavier demaison son
titre simplement son patronyme pour un
spectacle dans lequel il se raconte plus
que d'habitude
un troisième one man show qui joue
depuis deux ans dans toute la france il
sera vendredi et samedi 22 et 23 mars au
prisme à elancourt avant de jouer c'est
toute dernière date à l'olympia mi-avril
les mots serviteur de l'état
une entrée rock'n'roll pour un spectacle
tout en musique pour son numéro 5 steve
cholet a vu les choses en grand
ce soient les époques on continue
d'inventer des danses à la con souvenez
vous dans les années 70 avait ça
une première en janvier salle pleyel à
paris une tournée en france et en europe
francophone
l'humoriste chante danse et s'éclate sur
scène aux côtés de deux musiciens en
live
vous pouvez la retrouver samedi 23 mars
à la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux
calme-toi c'est un sketch héritiers de
guy bedos christophe alévêque revient
avec ses feuilles de notes et son
pupitre pour éplucher l'actualité au
sein de son spectacle revue de presse du
break site à la sphère benalla en
passant par les gilet jaune
rien n'échappe aux remarques cinglantes
de l'humoriste mais faut les comprendre
la violence par ailleurs dit ouais ils
ont traqué les trucs de violentes
bon c'est quand même plus excitant t-il
mais des bagarres des feux de voitures
des vitrines aux caciques que les gens
mal habillés qui défilent sans rien
faire qui change une partie de journée
il sera samedi 23 mars à l'espace albert
camus à maurepas pour vous prendront
complices de ces réflexions
humoristiques pendant près de deux
heures